You've done so many different things.
You ended up on Wall Street at one point.
Am I right? Did that happen
right after school? Or
what happened was I was,
I was so excited that I got
into Cornell that I found out,
and again, I was kind of figuring
this out on the fly, really been,
have parents that were guiding me on
this because they had no experience with
college. Right. And so, um,
I found out that there was an MBA program
at Cornell that you could do in one
year so you could finish Undergrad
and Grad and a five year program.
So I figured let's just
press my bets and go for it.
And I took a class to get familiar with
the MBA program and entrepreneurship
class and I won.
I won the entrepreneurship award.
So during that class I met a bunch of
judges who were very successful people
that had graduated Cornell,
gone on their own.
And in one of those judges
took a real liking to me.
I didn't make the MBA program,
they didn't accept me.
And I went back to queens to run that
swimming pool and construction business,
which was doing very,
very well at that point because I was
able to apply all the things I was
learning at Cornell to
my business. So, so, uh,
so I go back and I'm running
the business and that,
that judge stayed in touch with me. Many
calls me literally first of the month,
every month and says, when are you
gonna get out of the pool business?
You got to go to New York City.
And I was in queens and I said,
I'm doing really well. I met this
great girl, you know, I'm 22 years old.
I don't need to go to
Manhattan. And uh, he,
every month he drove me
crazy and one day he says,
I'm all right if you're not
going to listen to me. And now,
now I'm probably two years out of Cornell.
And he see that he's losing the battle.
And he says,
if you're not going to listen to,
I want you to buy this stock.
And I had never bought a stock before.
And um,
he tells me about a stock is in Texas.
There's a drug company now,
this is an older guy that that's been
trading and managing money for years.
And He'd been watching the
stock for 25 years and he says,
I want you to buy this stock. It's $14
a share. It's a, it's a drug company.
And he's an old time cape reader.
And I'm thinking, I don't want to,
I've been working so hard, I'm not
going to invest in a stock. I mean,
I remember the 87 crash.
I'm like, this guy is crazy.
And I go to one of my customer's House
that day that owed me quite a bit of
money for finishing a big
construction job he owed me.